danger Will Robinson your final season
is approaching that's a joke yeah
Netflix has announced a lust in space
the modern reimagining of the classic
60s TV series will come to an end after
its upcoming third season the final
go-round is expected to hit the streamer
sometime in 2021 that's too bad
the sci-fi revival got off to a bit of a
rough start when it debuted in April of
2018 critics generally agreed that it
looked gorgeous and was well acted by
its formidable cast the first season
however was taken to task in some
quarters for not having the narrative
ambition to match his impressive visuals
what happened there was an accident the
second season debuting in December 2019
was received much more warmly critics
appreciated the added dramatic heft the
batch of episodes brought to the story
of the marooned Robinson family and the
special effects were even more stunning
and elaborate than in the first outing
if he was ready for some binge watching
over the holiday season also flocked to
the series making a third season or both
inevitable so it was somewhat unexpected
that season 3 would actually be the
series last fortunately for the show's
fans however this wasn't really an
unexpected development according to
producer and showrunner zack estrin
Netflix didn't exactly pull the plug on
lost in space the streamer simply
followed the plan which Astra and crew
had had all along no not cool in a
statement following Netflix's
announcement astrid indicated that he
had always had a clear picture in his
head of where the robinson family's
adventures would take them and how this
story would eventually conclude the
statement explained from the beginning
we've always viewed this particular
story of the Robinsons as a trilogy a
three-part epic family adventure with a
clear beginning middle and then it's
also worth noting that with what these
characters go through just trying to
survive each episode if anyone deserves
to catch their breath before the next
mission it's will penny Judi Maureen
John Don West dr. Smith and the robots
and of course Debbie the chicken so
while this chapter of lost in space is
coming to a rousing conclusion I'm
excited about continuing to explore new
stories with my friends at Netflix
and for one of the incredible
possibilities that lie ahead while it
may be a bit disappointing for fans that
lost in space will be coming to a close
just as there appears to be picking up a
head of steam there's definitely
something to be said for the series
creative team having such a strong
vision for its narrative sure was such a
potentially open-ended premise a show
like lost in space could potentially go
on for season after season but more
often than not this is a recipe for even
the most well received shows to wear out
their welcome fans can at least be
reasonably assured that s Trading
Company will end this series on a high
note and that the Robinson family will
find closure in the final chapters of
their story ester in may not exactly be
a household name but he has a pretty
sterling record as a television producer
and writer he cut his teeth on the
series Charmed & Dawson's Creek and was
also an executive producer on Prison
Break which ran for five seasons
beginning in 2005 since then Estrella
has taken on a producing role on a
number of genres series including ABC's
the river zero hour and Once Upon a Time
In Wonderland Netflix was satisfied
enough for the performance of lost in
space that in conjunction with the
announcement of the series
discontinuation it was also revealed
that estrin has signed a multi-year
overall deal to develop and produce new
content for the streamer so while fans
of lost in space may be lamenting the
series and there are a couple of pretty
awesome takeaways here first that the
series will receive a planned epic
conclusion and second that is driving
creative force we'll be back with more
serialized goodness in the very near
future of course we'll be keeping an eye
out fest RINs upcoming projects to hit
the Netflix pipeline and we'll be sure
to keep you informed check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]